the Star of Bethlehem isn't actually
mentioned explicitly in the Bible
there's nothing called the Star of
Bethlehem but there is a star that leads
wise men or Magi to Bethlehem I mean
it's sort of often touted as potentially
an astronomical event that you know
these wise men coming from the east were
tipped off by some astronomical event
something going on in the sky this is
only in Matthew's it's only spoken about
in the Gospel of Matthew in Matthew
chapter 2 but there initially the star
doesn't lead the mage Isle the wise men
to Bethlehem at all it leads them to
Jerusalem and there they what they go to
King Herod who is the ruler of the Jews
and he says what well I'm not sure and
so he summons these sort of chief
priests and the scribes and asked them
where would the King of the Jews be born
and they reply with some words from
Micah that he'll be born in Bethlehem
and so this but over the years you know
it's one of those things that
astronomers like to play around with
because the nice thing is certainly some
things in astronomy we can actually date
extremely well we can actually predict
when things happen like when planetary
conjunctions when planets come close
together in the sky and those kinds of
things so it's kind of been a game that
astronomers have played from time to
time to try and predict what it might
have been so they went to Bethlehem and
Matthew introduces again saying that the
star guided them and was visible and so
with the help of the star in a way they
found the house and within the house the
mother and baby Joseph for example is
not mentioned at all in this scenery
there are lots of sort of astronomical
predictions possibilities as to what
this this strange event was that
precipitated the wise men wandering all
that distance all it says about the wise
men is that they come from the east
those from the east are interested in
things like astrology astronomy maybe
there's no distinction between these two
so it's surmised that because they've
seen this star because they've read the
symbols of the signs if you like and
said that this star means that a king of
the Jews is to be born then it says some
eyes that they are astrologers
as I say perhaps that you know the one
that's been around the longest then
perhaps the dullest is this thing called
a planetary conjunction where you have
say Saturn and Jupiter very close to
each other in the sky
and this is something that the
astrologers kind of get very hung up
about they think that it actually means
something of great significance when you
have one of these conjunctions
especially between the major planets so
the this is the the sky 12th of November
7 BC that you would have seen if you
were standing in the desert in Bethlehem
this is the southwestern sky and you can
see Saturn and Jupiter very close
together on the sky it's like half a
degree or a degree separate so if you
want I mean basically you know the
planets are a very distant very
different distances away from you and
they're both orbiting around the Sun at
their own speeds and once in a while
they just appear close to each other in
the sky they're not obviously physically
close to each other but it's just one's
more or less behind the other so they're
probably you know within half a degree
or so so within about the size of the
moon of each other this meeting in a way
was seen three three times because of
the different speed of the movement of
the planets although they just cross
each other once but it if you look from
the earth it looks as if they would meet
three times and this actually happens
from July till November this makes a lot
of sense in connection with ancient
astrology because the the planet Jupiter
and the planet Saturn they had a
specific meaning and this meaning can
also give a kind of background for the
story in Matthew the thing about
conjunctions is they happen all the time
you know there's one every few years I
made you one over a few years so it's
not very hard to come up with a major
conjunction occurring sometime around
the time of the wise men were probably
heading off towards Bethlehem and as
such you know it could be the
explanation but given that these
astrological conjunctions happen so
regularly why did that one Corps such a
major event in their lives and and
others didn't so true Peter is always
seen as a kind of kingly planet that
means he represents kingship because
he's the highest God in the Roman
pantheon and Saturn represents the
ancient god of Connor's that means of
time the the meeting point of this tool
planets actually happened within the
zodiacal constellation of Pisces and
Pisces was seen as a representative of
the land of esky lore of the this area
of Syria Palestine within the or on the
celestial map and so that means a king a
time time of a change of time and the
Land of Israel and this makes it
understandable that this wise man that
means these astronomers coming from the
east asked in Jerusalem who or where is
the newborn king of this country of the
choose there those planets were very
close together the whole year long yeah
this this is now thought to be the the
Star of Bethlehem especially because
there's I didn't show this but in the
ecliptic and the software doesn't show
that unfortunately in the ecliptic
there's a lot of dust so that would be
if you calculated this in there would be
a cone of light starting it's a certain
Jupiter and then lighting going going
towards the Earth
and so the other ones which are a little
harder to test is there are various
things that occur when stars blow up for
example so there's these thing called
supernovae which are kind of the death
throes of a star and then there are no V
which are kind of events very late on in
the lifetime of a star that don't
completely destroy the star but are kind
of in its final stages of its life and
these things are it can cause the
objects to brighten enormous Li so you
can actually have what appears to be a
blank patch of sky suddenly lighting up
with a with a what the ancients used
referred to as guest star something
which just lights up for a few weeks or
months and then goes away again and
obviously because these things are a lot
more random it's a lot harder to test
whether one of these things actually
hand in the right time frame because you
can't wind the clock back the way you
can with planetary conjunctions and say
ah yes one will definitely have happened
around then but the both the Koreans and
the chinese astronomers in that time
frame were actually recording these
events and there is actually they
recorded one of these guest stars
appearing again in this right time frame
of just in the immediate years bc
another important place that we have the
Star of Bethlehem is on top of our
Christmas trees so this is an excellent
example of a star there and another
comet which was a popular one for a long
time was Halley's Comet which comes
around very regularly in fact is a very
famous painting by Giotto showing that
the the adoration of the Magi and at the
time Giotto was making his painting
Hallie had just made one of its
appearances and so he actually sort of
borrowed it as to stand in for the Star
of Bethlehem so there was a famous
painting in which the the Star of
Bethlehem easily in fact shown as
Halley's Comet
Halley's Comet came around in 12 BC
which is a little uncomfortably early
you know people want this event to be
happening sort of somewhere between 5
and 10 BC so it's probably too early for
it to adays comment to have been the one
but there are other comets that just
come through the once and it could have
been a comet